hey I was gonna ease today we are going
to do something new and exciting for
this channel we are opening a Pokemon
Trading Card Game
plasma blast it's super popular right
now it's the hip thing to open card game
cards I don't I don't get it
but we're gonna do it and there's gonna
be epic music in the background and it's
gonna be there's gonna be the place
maybe the best thing has ever happened
to anyone so I'm getting a little
excited alright so here's here's the
pack
I can't wait to [ __ ] see what's up
don't look look good [ __ ] out of the way
first though I need to get prepared the
card opening we have horses standard
piece of [ __ ] card I'm gonna pull from
the bottom and then then we can see
they're like where he goes alright here
we go
porygon yeah that's [ __ ] love Arista I
asked [ __ ] [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] car I'm
always so [ __ ] unlucky with [ __ ]
cards match what he stays snubber yeah
that's that's pretty good a lot I like a
snubber X ooh yeah that [ __ ] sucks
oh no no [ __ ] way
Sherri's art I got a shadow in power
kind of funny shirt
we still have a few cards to go let's oh
all right thank you okay next I'm Rena
compose no no don't don't don't
Jared I don't know Tara's art and this
one has what it says it's laminated
laminated dark Arianism it has old brain
on it
oh my god sickest most badasses all man
mom mom
I don't leave my mom anymore oh my god
uh I can't eat this
we still have like five cards to go so
why I am I'm done for life I'm done for
life Henry oh my dog and energy it's
like I get a good car now and I don't
know it's not even that big deal anymore
no no no it's it's a chair sorry we have
one more card life so okay we have one
more card life with soup
Pikachu Pikachu level hundred big I
think I tap on Pikachu is it's not like
this video
nothing has ever been greater than this
moment in my life I'm gonna go and I'm
gonna never come back
nothing to pee get you at you like this
video for more next episode we're gonna
open the next episode we're gonna we're
gonna open a can of milk